welcome to exploring computing
today's video is creating web pages
specifying colors so if you haven't
already watched the hexadecimal
numbers video watch that first
hexadecimal numbers are critical to
working with
colors on web pages for cs 105 students
that video
is in the same folder as this video
for cs106e students we covered hex
decimal numbers last week
in the lo6 memory lecture series
also as a reminder of how the computer
actually generates colors
it mixes the amount of red green and
blue on each of the sub pixels composing
each of the individual pixels in the
screen
so remember when we're specifying colors
we're specifying the intensity of red
green and blue
we learned that the first week in the
lecture on
images okay so let's start off with a
little history lesson
this will tie back in once upon a time
we had only 16 named colors
and here they are so we'll see in a
minute you guys have it much better off
but there was another big problem that
we had which was that the computer
monitors only display 256 colors
and it turns out that
the computer manufacturers could not
agree on what those 256 colors were
so there were only 211 colors that were
agreed upon by all the computer
manufacturers and these were referred to
as the
web safe colors so if you see the term
web safe color
that's what they're referring to it
should not be an issue any longer
because
any modern computer display or mobile
device
should display 16.7 million colors or
more i don't think you're going to run
into
devices that only have 256 colors but
you will run into the term web safe
color
that is what it's referring to
okay what do we have now well as far as
named colors go there are 148 named
colors
and as we've talked about previously
there are 16.7 million colors
as you learned about in the first week
how computer store and display images
and in addition to having 16.7 million
colors we also have 256
levels of transparency in computer
science we usually refer to this as
alpha
but it corresponds to either
transparency or its opposite
opacity the name colors are
what are sometimes referred to as the
css3 that's cascading style sheet three
there are several versions of cascading
style sheets they're starting to work on
cascading style sheets for but they
haven't really finished cascading style
sheets 3 yet
the cascading style sheet 3 had an
extended color standard
and these are referred to as the css3
extended color keywords or the svg that
scalar vector graphics
which we talked about briefly in our
lecture on image representation
that's the object version of storing
image information that is available on
the web
we may talk about that again in more
detail another lecture
it's also referred to as the svg 1.0
color keyword names
these are sometimes also referred to as
html5 colors
although that is not technically correct
you may also hear them refer to
just css colors i'm not going to list
all 148 of them but
this kind of gives you a feel for what
sort of
options you have available there are
quite a few options
there's a lot going on there but they
are nowhere near the full color palette
remember we can represent 16.7 million
colors
and the extended color keywords only
give us 148.
so i think they're they're fun
if nothing else and they may give you
some ideas on colors to play with
but they are not they're they're fairly
limited
now when we're looking at these sample
lists here
we've got the name that's pretty obvious
what that is
and then we have the representation of
the color and it's pretty obvious what
that is
and then what is between those two that
thing that starts with a number sign
well if you've watched the hexadecimal
video you will know that that is
the hexadecimal color specification
and if you haven't watched the
hexadecimal video yet watch the
hexadecimal video
all right so as we saw in the
and as you recall from our discussion on
uh computer displays and images from the
first week
computers used 24-bit color or 32-bit
color
and in either one of these two schemes
colors are represented by mixing red
green and blue light
and red corresponds to a single byte
green corresponds to single byte and
blue corresponds to single byte
that gives us decimal numbers between 0
and 255 but it gives us hexadecimal
numbers between
0 0 and ff and for the web
they're traditionally represented as hex
decimal numbers and so here we've got
cardinal red
and it would be represented by the
sequence eight c one
five one five so six hexadecimal digits
two hexadecimal digits for red
two hexadecimal digits for green two
hexadecimal digits for blue
and as you'll recall from the
hexadecimal discussion
each hexadecimal digit corresponds to
four bits
so two hexadecimal digits corresponds to
eight bits which is a byte so that's
where
we get our successes and decimal digits
24 bit color i think the most important
thing to understand
as far as hexadecimal goes when we're
working with html
and web pages and cascading style sheets
and colors
is how to make adjustments so here i've
got
a crimson red and we're using crimson
red
although we saw cardinal red a moment
ago because cardinal red is perfect we
don't want to modify cardinal red but we
might want to play with our crimson red
so this is crimson red dc143c
and so when you look at this color you
might think
i think there's a little bit too much
red so
what you want to do is you want to be
able to look at this and say well
that first pair of hexadecimal digits
that dc
that's the amount of red and so i can
move the amount of red up or down
so like if i wanted to move it up if i
wanted to move it up slightly
you know what it comes above dc well dd
comes above dc
and then d e and then df and then e0
right or we can go in the other
direction and say okay dc's too much
let me reduce it very slightly db
um da d9 d8
and so be able to move up and down now
you're probably not going to be moving
up by
increments of one that's that's really
but maybe your eyesight and artistic
abilities are such that
you might notice the difference i'm not
going to be able to know it's different
so i would move it up much
more or move it down much more so here
i've moved it down to
ac and you can see that
this is a considerably darker red than
we started off with
um so you know again say we wanted to
uh adjust the amount of blue
maybe one we want a little bit more blue
so i could i remember okay ac
that's now our red 1-4 that's our green
and three c is our blue
and so if i want to move blue up 3c what
comes after 3c
e 3 f 4 0 or if i want to go down from 3
c
3 b 3 a
3 9 and so on again those are minor
adjustments i'm going to make a much
bigger adjustment here i'm going to take
the 3c and just boost up to 5c
and you can see the results here so
basically you want to be able to take
these color specifications
and have a good enough understanding of
hexadecimal to be able to
make adjustments up or down
so focus on understanding how to
increase and decrease the hexadecimal
numbers rather than worrying about how
to convert to decimal
now if you look at this little overlay
that i've got here you may notice that
you can kind of see
the color squares behind it and so this
is an example of using alpha
to alpha controls again either the
opacity
or the transparency the two are
basically opposites opacity
says how much are we preventing the
light from coming through and
transparency says how much are we
allowing the light to come through
so in addition to being able to specify
the amount of red green and blue
we have we can also add in fourth pair
of hexadecimal digits to control
the alpha so here eight c one five one
five that's our crimson red
but um that's actually clover of eight c
one five one five that's rgb
and then ff that is the uh that last
set of hexadecimal digits is the alpha
and with ff that's the
maximum that we're allowed to specify
and so this is full opacity this means
we cannot see through this at all and so
you can see the example overlay title
and then a crimson background using the
color i've specified here and you cannot
see through that
uh crimson at all so we're going to
reduce it slightly
here's 75 i've gone from ff to bf
and if you look at the example overlay
over our image of vanish you can see
you're starting to be able to see
venice through the crimson background
there
and that's because it's not at full
opacity it's now at only 75
opacity we can lower it even more this
is a about 50
opacity um i specified that last pair of
uh that fourth pair of hexadecimal
digits again
representing the opacity i've cut it
down from ff all the way down to eight
zeros this is
basically halfway you can see you can
see a lot more of
the background showing through so that
kind of gives you an idea of how to play
around with the alpha if you want to do
that
you can also use three or four digit
colors instead of instead of using
six or eight digit colors and so what
happens here is we take
uh let's start for the three digit
example we take our original rgb
and we just get rid of you know have the
number of
uh letters so as long as our pairs are
you know both the tens well
they're not really tens i suppose
they're sixteens as long as the sixteens
and the ones
are the same if we were using decimal it
would be the tens and the ones
we can immediately convert it to three
hexadecimal digits
and i've written these down as they're
equal that's not really true
it's more the ffff is transformed into
fff uh they're not you know if we were
to do the actual conversion
in base 16 these of course are not equal
but as far as how they're specified
um in this three three digit scheme
uh for colors that's the way it works so
similarly cc
9900 can just be written as c90
and one one aa33 could be written as 1a3
if you work this out what ends up
happening here is
we're losing the number of colors we can
specify
with our original 8 hexadecimal digit
scheme remember that corresponds to 24
bits and so 2 to the 24 gives us 16.7
million colors
with the three hexadecimal digit scheme
we've only got 12 bits as that gives us
2 to the 12th which means we have 4096
colors so basically you're losing the
ability to specify a lot of colors
but you know unless you're fine-tuning
things you may not notice
it it just really depends on what you're
doing and you can also specify these
with
four hexadecimal digits where the fourth
hexadecimal digit corresponds to the
amount of alpha
so how do we take these specifications
and actually use them on a web page so
here's a short little example
showing how i used some colors so
i've created a style sheet i'm
specifying
a style rule for the body and you can
see
i'm providing the color and background
color properties
and for color i'm just using one of
those predefined
color names wheat and then for the
background color i'm using my
hexadecimal specifications take the
specifications we've been showing you
here and slap them in the style sheet
anywhere at color is expected
now if you are hexadecimally challenged
it is possible to
do it without the hexadecimals
traditionally it is done by hexadecimals
and the hexadecimal
colors are going to show up in a lot of
places so
you know i do think that you should try
and get at least some familiarity with
them
you should be familiar enough with them
that when you see them you're like
oh that's a color and i can kind of get
a sense by looking at the r
the g and the b at more or less
what it might look like but if you
really don't want to specify the amounts
in hexadecimal you can specify them
either as
percentages or as just straight decimal
numbers so this is
going to be instead of specifying the
number as
number sign hexadecimal pair hexadecimal
pair hexadecimal pair
you can specify it use vibrating rgb
and then giving a set of percentages for
red green and blue
or you can give numbers between 000 and
255.
this also works for alpha you specify
alpha as a percentage
and then finally we'll talk about this
later in the quarter when we're talking
about uh website design
but depending on what you're doing you
may want to
specify instead of rgb you could specify
using hue saturation and
lightness this will be useful when
you're trying to choose
color schemes um and again we will talk
about this later
and here's what this looks like on an
actual web page
uh inside this style sheet
all right so this is kind of giving me a
sense of how colors are specified
on web pages and now between the images
we talked about earlier and the colors
we specified here
you should be able to make much more
interesting and fun web
pages i'll talk to you soon